adam is the most excited about this
episode in fact it was his idea
so toast that's right we were pretty
excited to try
a bunch of bread for an episode adam had
the brilliant idea of
looking at bread worlds through
the ship of toast so today not only are
we going to three restaurants but we're
also going to a couple of
bakeries this is really going to be a
jam-packed episode wow today i'm worth
it
we're going to be trying three awesome
toast dishes at three drastically
wait not so drastically different price
points to find out which one is the most
worth it at its price
fyi the toast we're doing these are not
your average toast
it's not your side toast this toast is
entre toast you ready
toast me
i'm jessica koslow you're here at
squirrel in silver lake today we're
trying our ricotta toast the poster
child of sweet food here at squirrel the
squirrel started in 2011
as a jam company when we started we
really only had this space here so we
were doing pretty much everything on
toast
all the jams are made here fresh in
copper pans like
it is all labor the jams are made by han
ricotta and all of these things
the only thing that's not is the bread
because we don't have the space and that
is why we find really special producers
like love and grandmas for our whitefish
tartine
we use clark street baguettes for this
chickpea dish
that has basically a sword where we cut
the baguette from tip to tail
for the ricotta toast we use a fluffy
brioche
that we get from farm shop brioche is
actually pretty simple ingredients it
has flour
yeast salt sugar and then the enrichment
part there's milk there's eggs and
there's butter we are using california
butter
it's high butter fat so you're looking
at like 80 we're also using california
cage-free eggs and we will shape it
it'll go into the pre-sprayed pans that
we've got ready to go our loaf pans
where you have a dome top which is what
the ones we're making for squirrel and
the challenge of making the round top
rios versus the flat pullman loaves
it's the mixing process so if the mixing
isn't done enough then you're going to
have gaps
and depending on how the bread proofs
you might have holes it's a different
game and a flat base bridge and then
it is packed early in the morning and
then it'll get shipped cut size is
pretty thick we
roll it on a butter wheel so we butter
it on both sides and then we put it into
a panini press it's a flat painting
press on both sides so it's warm
it's griddled and then we let it rest
for a second we put the ricotta on
we make it from strauss organic cream we
strain it we add about
90 percent cream by weight back into the
ricotta and we whip it by hand and so it
is a fluffy
type of ricotta a lot of times people
want a rainbow so they get three flavors
of jam
it does rotate with the season so right
now we'll do blueberry rhubarb raspberry
cardamom
strawberry rose geranium we finish it
with a squeeze of fresh lemon juice
and a sprinkle of maldon sea salt so at
farm shop they were saying you're the
only one who doesn't have the flat
top bread why it looks like a mushroom
it's really fun you know if you're
paying eight dollars for a ricotta toast
it better look fun and it better look
ridiculous and big
and that's exactly what it does so first
of all cheers
tonic turmeric tonic
that's nice is it ginger oh it's so good
turmeric
look at this toast whoa i just got a big
whiff of the
jam yeah this is beyond toast
this is my actual face look at this
scale
all right shall i cut you a little cube
please whoa
i will say i've never seen ricotta
presented in this fashion
toast nailed it
oh my god of all the elements of this
toast
the toast is really just the presenter
here
it's amazing it's doing its job the
ricotta is
insane it's so it's whipped so lightly
yes
and it's cheese okay next gem
that gem this is a jam story yes
this is like when you're reading red
riding hood you think it's about a
little girl but really it's about a
badass wolf
it's like the best parts of a jam
sandwich that i had
and french toast and cake
but light like a whipped cream
mix that in a bottle and you got ricotta
toast look at the toast
i love the edges of toast you get the
crust
the crust is a must super delicious it's
adam's turn
ricotta toast on brioche
with jam at squirrel cafe is it called
squirrel cafe i don't know but i'm
really into this like back and forth
thing we just built a sentence together
i
love toast boom we're here in
retown and we're going to a restaurant
called here's looking at you
whoa you look at me right when i said
that i thought i was going to have to
finish part of the
my bad here's looking at you there we go
we're gonna have some pate some cheese
a savory toast that's better than most
i'm jonathan whitener i'm the chef owner
of here's looking at you and
we're gonna try chicken liver mousse and
stretchy jello cheese today what kind of
establishment
is here's looking here we're like a
progressive kind of southern california
restaurant the repertoire is french at
heart but executed with all types of
different cultures
when did toast become like a meal good
bread is a vessel
for everything that you're trying to
make there wasn't until i met andy from
bob and grandma's our signature dishes
involve bob's bread
it's such a quintessential part of the
restaurant this bread has a perfect
balance of texture and flavor
the aeration of it and the fact that he
cooks with passion actually implements
on the food part of our thing is
creating a happy place to work
that doesn't push people away from their
families and friends and it translates
into the products that come out the door
we use higher percentage whole grain
than most other bakers in town i feel
like there's more flavor in the whole
grains it helps to
move people more towards real bread as
opposed to chemically engineered bread
it's a three-day process basically we
mix weight out fins they start
fermenting throughout the three-hour
bulk fermentation
we do folds on the dough to build
strength basically building a scaffold
inside that holds in all those co2
bubbles so that it doesn't collapse in
the oven shaping it into a bowl goes in
the baskets goes in the walk-in
come in the next morning straight out of
the baskets they flip onto the loader
and then they bake
max is going to score these because when
we do our final shape the exterior of
the loaves are made strong enough to
hold the thing up so now we want to
actually release that tension so that
they can rise to their fullest potential
in the oven caring is number one like
i'm just a really anxious person and if
things aren't perfect i kind of
they need to be which these guys do it's
personal like especially when you get up
early in the morning like this and
sacrifice part of your normal life to
come work here
you have to care and this bread is epic
you know we hit it with a lot of olive
oil to help get a really good char on it
and just slap it on the grill we have a
wood burning grill burns at like 700
degrees a lot of our clients feel like
it's supposed to be burnt like this and
it's like
yeah a lot of people don't realize that
burning stuff like that not even smoking
is a technique of cooking
the chicken liver boots we use really
high quality jadori chicken livers i
actually take my maple syrup and smoke
it and then we add that to the liver we
serve it with a side of bubb's bread
and then pickled pea pyres which are
like a spanish best peppers
all right we've got this beautiful rose
we do i know you love the color of
yeah so this is our first
build your own toast segment you get to
control your
flavors a little bit more do you want to
try the bread on its own i actually
really do because he was
really talking up andy's bread cheers
oh yeah
already look at the aeration on that
bread inside it's just like you're just
saying aeration because you heard the
chef say alright
look at the texture yeah look at the
bread all right here it comes
you want to get that nice and smeared on
whoa yeah i used to think that trains
were the perfect vehicle
no bread is the perfect vehicle of
flavor it almost tastes
aged yeah yeah let me try that
the stretchy is the cheese that we get
from joya as a local producer here we
make this
kind of like a japanese pesto so we use
japanese parsley shinkiku which is a
chrysanthemum leaf perilla some cilantro
and then yusukosho and mix that all
together like a pretty smooth pesto put
that on top of the cheese
toasted pumpkin seeds on top and then
serve it with bubs bread round two baby
we got a chardonnay
also bubbly do you know any foreign
language toasts
yeah like in korean chan in chinese is
kambe
kampe in ukrainian it's nazarovia oh i
like that how do you say that
nasia roga nazdarovia
you know what let's do some toast so now
we've upgraded to a
deeper vessel hell yeah we got
soft cheese that is the realm i like to
live in
god yeah see that's what you want in
cheese
yeah it's got like creamy
a little messy a little stringy but it's
a cool cheese don't think this is hot
and melty um
mm-hmm that's the one yeah i'm not
crying it's so good
this tastes like both the milk fresh
from the cow
and the grass that the cow is standing
on in a very delicious way not a gross
way
i think the amount of time it takes to
chew a piece of bread really says
something about how good it is
here's the thing i've had good bread
before but i didn't realize that
bread could be like this luxurious yeah
like this epic you take it for granted
for sure you'll get in here adam
yeah adam you gotta get in here
premium ice cream here's to eating toast
yo that toast was
crazy that was delicious yeah it was
crazy delicious all right where we going
next andrew
we're going to san francisco to have
some 20 toast
san francisco yeah to not have toast but
to have
a tartine which is terrible which is
that's toast
that's toast right well is it toast it's
toasters we're choosing to call toast
hi i'm dominique hen and this is one of
my restaurants
called patikren it's a very casual
french bistro
it's an homage to my mother and my
grandmother cooking from brittany the
focus here
is just vegetable and seafood there is
no meat
you have another restaurant here in san
francisco yes i do have
and that's the restaurant that's kind of
my baby actually clean and this is a
dish that is
kind of a take on a dish that i used to
do at actually crane on the testing menu
called the walk in the forest
i used to go to the forest with my dad
often and he's used to have blackberry
and
mushroom and wetness outside and that
smell and that funkiness
so it's kind of a take on and hey let's
do a mushroom tart in here
and how you can bring the mushroom to
the next level without killing it you
take the bread
grill it on the grill we get different
type of mushrooms each is varied
through the season saute the mushroom
with a little bit of butter
a little bit of olive oil neglect them
with cherry vinegar
what we want to achieve is to glaze the
mushroom
with the butter and just make them like
just a little bit of acidic also with
the vinegar
you have to test your food you have to
know what you're putting on the place
you have to understand the balance you
know it's very important we made a
espalette mayonnaise there is a lot of
umami and
there's a lot of fat in that dish so you
want to cut that with a little bit of a
cornichon
elephant garlic different type of herb
finish with a little bit of sea salt
curd it
eat it and go to sleep when you have a
bread and you know there is a lot of
work behind it and you know it's
delicious
less is more less is always more i think
so
yeah what do i know
cheers
have you ever seen a funner color but
this is natural
it is and beautiful tasting speaking of
beautiful
look at that i'll split the toast please
part of the forest
[Music]
i have no words it's interesting because
mushroom is far from the predominant
flavor
on this routine it's there and it's
delicious but the balance of
little acidic things yes totally perfect
this is extremely delicious i think more
than anything i'm devastated by
things that i've worked so much harder
and longer on
that didn't taste nearly as good yeah
unless it's more though
if you know how to do it right right
right
[Music]
what a toasty episode we just had but
i'm chilly
hey don't get jelly of my worth at
winner
because my worth at winner on this very
special episode
is squirrel oh yeah
that was a very worth it piece of toast
why
three kinds of very special jelly and a
whipped ricotta on a sick brioche
come on that's very worth it yeah i mean
wow i can't believe you're choosing
that as you're worth it winner believe
it
my worth at winner wait can adam can you
go first please
adam who's you're worth it winner oh
adam said here's looking at you adam
says the liver moose whoa
all right so yeah but the crane is not
worth the winner that was
it was delicious that's a good choice
that is a very strong
toast game coming out of petite creme
but i i don't feel good
saying it because they were all so good
did you know that tip was included
for that tartine oh yeah that does it
for me then yeah there you go
done that was a very fun episode not a
crazy high price point but for a food
like toast
uh still pretty interesting you saw a
couple bakeries you saw some bread get
baked you saw some toast get toasted
come on it was a great time we just had
together so uh all of us
we'll be back next week me adam
and all y'all toast oh yes